foreign
[Music]
foreign
months after Russia's Siege on the city
of maryupal which saw some of the war's
worst fighting Julia sazonova's husband
Vladimir and thousands of others are
still unaccounted for
now Russian troops patrolled the largely
empty streets of this strategic Southern
Port City that was once home to almost
450
000 people
those that remain are largely cut off
from the outside world
foreign
the United Nations estimates as many as
90 of residential buildings were damaged
or destroyed in the battle for mariupo
now entire housing blocks are being
demolished
and Russia is rapidly erecting new
complexes as families scramble to find
the dead and missing before it's too
late raising fears that evidence of war
crimes and any trace of the missing
could be wiped away forever
this video is pieced together from
hundreds of social media videos over the
last five months video diaries from two
women searching for loved ones and from
volunteers assisting with the effort to
get a glimpse of the rush to locate the
missing
since the siege ended in May Yulia and
many others have been using any
resources they can access to find their
loved ones enlisting volunteers
scouring telegram channels and posting
missing notices around the city
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a group of friends who used to post
YouTube videos of gymnastic tricks began
filming themselves exploring the city
after it fell
commenters soon asked them to search for
the missing
during The Siege many people took
shelter in basements
While others fled the city with
Communications down and their lives
thrown into chaos thousands of people
lost contact with each other
Katarina lost touch with Alexei in early
March shortly after the War Began
after living through attacks on the city
for more than a month she and her family
were eventually evacuated and settled in
Germany in June
that same month she reached out to a
volunteer who identifies himself as
Dimitri in his YouTube videos to look
for Alexei at his home on cuprina Street
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Katarina tried following the leads from
alexei's Neighbors with little luck
Yulia has filed reports with Russia's
occupying forces as she works to piece
together what happened to her husband
since he disappeared in March during a
brief walk home
[Music]
is
with leads on the ground coming up short
Yulia and Katarina both wondered if
their loved ones might be in prison
somewhere Katarina turned to the
internet for help
um
cabrina Street where Alexa was living is
a particularly Stark example of the
rapid pace of Russia's rebuilding of the
city in recent months
the boys search for people at 69 cuprina
Street in August
thanks uh
since August we found at least six
buildings have been demolished on one
side of the street
recent satellite imagery shows one of
those buildings was 69 cuprina Street
the new Russian buildings are visible on
the other side of the street
the arrival of winter and maryupal
brings the contrasting conditions of the
city into Focus
shining new apartment complexes continue
to appear
as the boys encounter residents living a
drastically different reality
foreign
still searching desperately hope their
loved ones are alive videos of growing
burial sites in mariu Bull have been
circulating for months
they show fresh Graves marked with
numbers in the thousands
authorities in mariable have said that
DNA samples of the Dead were taken so
that missing people can be traced in the
future
experts in finding missing people in
Conflict say it will take years to
locate those who are still unaccounted
for
and it's unlikely everyone will be found
the Russian Embassy in Washington DC did
not respond to requests for comment
regarding the whereabouts of missing
persons in Mary upel and concerns that
human remains are being discarded
uh
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]